all right amisha yes i'm misha where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally
i'm originally from belize moved out
here to the states
started in arkansas and then moved to
long beach with my mom my dad
they were married he was in and out of
prison so then she
turned out to have parties and drinking
and smoking and fighting
and me my sister my brother all have
different fathers
um i would say i'm the black sheep
because i was always the one getting
beat
norm pulled by my hair hit with irons
broomsticks
having carpet burns um black eyes and
that all started with my mother
i had to take care of my little sister
and my little brother at six years old i
learned how to
cook i learned how to change diapers i
learned how to
potty train a boy because my mom was
never home
where was mom running the streets
probably prostituting i know she had her
head busted one time
and she came home with a shower cap on
her head and
had blood all in it and i don't know if
the guy was trying to rape her or robber
or she was
probably trying to rob him i don't know
um
so when i would get up and go to school
i would fix their food
i would pack her my my sister's diaper
bag
and to send them next door but the next
door neighbor was a hairnet
so i pretty much grew up around a whole
bunch of chaos
father got out of prison came got me
brought me to california los angeles
with his side of the family needless to
say
same events i was a black sheep i was
always in trouble i was ditching school
i didn't listen i had
the c average my cousin was a average
she went to the magnet school and i was
worthless because
that's just not what i wanted to do um
he went back to prison so i was stuck
with my grandma
and my auntie and then i hadn't seen my
mom for years i didn't see my mom again
until i was about
maybe 14. um
and i tried to talk to her about her
situation with me and her
and she told me that i was lying mind
you
at six years old i got raped three times
the first time i told my mother
she called me lying [ __ ] and slapped me
so as a result i never said anything
else and it happened two more times
at the age of 14 i got raped
and then at the age of 16 i got raped by
three men back to back for seven days
held at gunpoint
in detroit they kidnapped me from
eaglewood and they knocked me out
and i woke up in a car bouncing
i had to peed on myself and everything
and the next thing i know i was in
detroit
i had my jaw broken i've been stabbed
with an ice pick
i've been robbed i've been held at
gunpoint i've been slammed up against a
brick wall i've been in a car accident
where i almost broke my spine
i left home when i was 16. i've been
down here on skid row
i don't got into with other men i don't
got
cut down here um i have bruises all over
me i have a big
burn mark on my leg for where a man
tried to set me on fire
um i mean i don't know i just been
through a lot
i've been to a lot my daddy died when i
was 17
which in turn means in all actuality i
have four years with him out of my whole
entire life so you were on your own
since when oh didn't have nobody nobody
his mother died 2000 he died 2001
and my mother's mother died 2002 so but
when you were 16 you were
on your own what were you doing then
i was prostituting i was robbing people
i was in and out of jails i was in and
out of institutions
i was just running rapid
because it's like i was on my own i had
nowhere to go i didn't know what to do
and i was young and drugs are part of
the picture too
they became a part of the picture when i
got down here maybe a year
and a half i was almost 18. i was
drinking first no i was smoking weed
then i was drinking
and then graduated to crack
and you're still using today i still
drink a drink
and do you have kids i have two kids
which are with their dad because of my
lifestyle
i'm was incapable of taking care of kids
because i was too busy
in the streets being a street woman so
did you feel like you're following your
mom's footsteps
a little bit but i think i was worse
i think i had a lot of resentments
against her
for telling me i was lying for beating
on me
then i had resentments against my dad
for in and out of prison
and then dying and leaving me lonely so
i feel neglected
lonely abandoned you know i'm just
i'm everywhere so you think you have a
victim
mentality i used to
now i think i've took the role of kind
of victimizing people
like i'm very angry
where i fight a lot like i you don't
have to say much and i'll hit you first
i just anything makes me snap
i don't like people behind me
i just i'm not a people person
not because i don't trust nobody where
are you living today
in a tent right
you still have contact with your kids i
haven't talked to my daughter
in about a year my son in about two
years
what's the hardest thing of all your
your life here on the streets
the hardest thing in my life not being
around my kids
feeling like i'm the worst mother ever
in feeling low self-esteem and low
self-worth because i feel like nobody
values me so i don't even know how to
value myself
nobody seemed to value you when you were
a kid
so where would you have learned it from
exactly
dear friends i don't believe in friends
you ever been in love no
do you feel like anybody loved you as a
child
my dad your dad did
about him being taken so early
i don't know now i don't feel like it
what's been the hardest thing for you to
go through
just being by myself and wishing my dad
was here to help me
do you think maybe you're addicted to
this life street life
honestly i ain't dislike but i don't
know how to get out
do you have a record that would keep you
from getting work and all that i've been
in jail for
sales dui so
i i have a record
[Music]
so it's not just a drug addiction
there's also violence
how did you first get introduced to
crime uh
my i was not my first
so-called with my second when he i
actually i went to a program for when i
started drinking and i made him a
program
and he was doing cracking and i was just
alcoholic so
when we did our six months we left
together
and then we got into it and he was
smoking and that's how it happened
it just but today alcohol is your big
yeah your main go-to and that's my first
like i
i won't leave alcohol for that that's
like my best friend right now
how do you how bad is your alcohol
uh when i wake up i shake
so you first thing you do is you start
drinking
[Music]
what's your drink i drink anything that
says liquor
do you feel like the the the rapes that
you
went through as a kid were the most
pivotal thing that happened to you as a
child
i mean that your mom was in and out yeah
i was in and out
was actually the most traumatic thing as
being six-year-old
besides my mama beating me like i was a
note
because i felt like she hated me
and i was when i knew early
and i never got any answers so
how did your siblings do
well somebody called
and said my mom was doing heroin because
she used to hang with the lady next door
and i can't say if she was or she went
but it didn't seem like she was
and so my sister went
with her dad's mom
and my brother went with my mom's mom
and then i went with my dad
so we all kind of like got separated
and then my brother went to a
a group home and my sister don't even
know who i
am but i know
her because i used to change her diapers
do you feel betrayed by everybody you
grew up with
no not betrayed just like
how was the mistake of being here
because it seemed like everybody
hates me that i try to consider loving
what's been your darkest what's been
your roughest
point the roughest part of my life
the day my dad died
it was this summer i graduated high
school
and i graduated july 21st and he died
august 7.
do you even feel like you deserve a
better life i mean it sounds like you
never oh no
you're never shown that you deserve
anything no how far did you go in school
i graduated to upgrade and i tried
cosmetology culinary arts
and uh child development but
i never could finish because
i was too used to drinking and smoking
and i just felt like school was just
taking them so i just dropped out i
stopped
do you feel like you'll be down here the
rest of your life sometimes
you've been down here your whole life
right just about
i'm 37.
what do you think would help you the
most right now
somebody that actually loves me enough
to really help me
understand me sometimes listen to me
i did i don't know
the biggest thing that i want that would
help me
especially spiritually it's just
somebody that loves
anything that i love them and i can't
show trust love to nobody because
i never get it so i stay bottled up
and i stay angry i don't want to be
angry but down here you have to
because they take advantage of you they
beat on you they
rape you they drug you with all kind of
stuff
when you're a little girl did you have
dreams of doing something
with your life i've always wanted to own
my own daycare
because i love kids
what do you feel like is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
you've been through so much
[Music]
that god doesn't put more on me than i
can bear cause i'm still here
all right amish i'm going to give you
something to make your weekend a little
easier
hopefully you don't spend it on alcohol
i already have
alcohol
thank you time felt good to let
somebody know yeah